Bitte schön.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gürbüz. Ich bin als Assistant der Sinteti in der Notaufnahme.
Und wir haben gerne mit Ihnen das Gespräch über das Stass für die Inordnung.
Ja.
Kursum ablau.
So ersperrte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person.
Ich stelle Ihnen das Kommissoffersort von Ihren Appellinbecher.
Okay?
Ja, ist okay.
Wie heißt es Sie?
Ich heiße Claudia Morgenstern.
Könnten Sie bitte Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja.
L, A, U, D, I, A.
Claudia.
I, A, M.
Und Morgenstern, der Nachname.
M, O, R, G, E, N.
Morgen.
Ja, S, T, E, R, N.
Ja, voraus Morgenstern. Wie alt sind Sie?
64.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1858.
Okay.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege jetzt 60 Kilo.
Und bin 1 Meter 66 groß.
Okay.
Was für Beschwärzen haben Sie für Morgenstern?
Wie kann ich ihn heißen?
Ja, ich habe seit heute Morgen oder seit gestern.
Also seit knapp einem Tag habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Die werden immer schlimmer.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie bitte zeigen?
Mir so in der Mitte des Bauches.
Okay.
Ein bisschen nach rechts ziehend.
Mit dem Bauch so ein bisschen rechts.
Okay, die Schmerzen lokalisieren um Narben herum.
Stimmt?
Ja, ungefähr um den Bauchnabel.
Etwas oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen ein Auflöse ehrenerlich für die Schmerzen?
Nee.
Sind Sie plössisch aufgetreten?
Ja, relativ langsam.
Langsam.
Dann wurde es dann doch schnell stärker.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte bis zum Ende Aussaal zu bebrauchen,
die Schmerzen mit der Jetzt?
Nein, ich kann es im Augenblick noch aushalten.
Ja, das wäre gut, danke schön.
Und Schmerzen, die Schmerzen, irgendein Bohinaus?
Nee, wir sind mehr so im Bauch nur.
Nein, Bein oder so, nee.
Okay.
Können Sie bitte dünn, genau, wenn Sie dünn sind,
eher dumpf, oder dürrkend, oder krampfartig?
Im Anfang waren Sie mehr dumpf.
Und jetzt sind Sie schon so ein bisschen
wellenförmig, die kommen und gehen.
Okay.
Stark und dann werden Sie wieder etwas weniger,
oder Sie sind immer da.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lehnt, oder verstellt?
Also wenn ich mich hinlege, auf die Seite lege
und die Knie etwas so anziehe,
dann habe ich den Eindruck, ist es etwas besser.
Okay.
Und wie ist es, wenn die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalaphone
nur ein bisschen, wobei nur keine Schmerzen,
sind zerstarkische Schmerzen in Schmerzen.
Wenn Sie ganz stark sind, acht.
Okay.
Aber sind ja so wellenförmig.
Und dann gehen Sie wieder zurück, vielleicht bis auf fünf.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie andere Bescheiden?
Ich meine Übelkeit, Erbrechen oder Durchfall.
Mir ist jetzt zunehmend übel in den letzten Stunden.
Erbrechen noch nicht so richtig, aber ich habe etwas Brechreiz.
Also das kann sein, dass es bald kommt,
dass ich erbrechen muss.
Aber ich komme noch nicht.
Appetit habe ich jetzt gar nicht.
Und Durchfall habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Zuletzt auf dem Klo für zwei Tagen habe ich Stuhlgang gehabt.
Keine Durchfall.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe aber nicht gemessen,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen etwas unauffälliges aufgefallen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich mit dem Essen nicht zusammenhängt.
Okay.
Ich habe es gelassen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser?
Nein.
Normalerweise gehe ich einmal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Aber das ist schon seit einem Jahr.
Ich habe es gelassen.
Aber das ist schon seit einigen Jahren.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Dann schlafe ich wieder ein.
Okay, ich fange da.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Brust schmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
In letzter Zeit fühle ich mich etwas mehr müde
und abgeschlagen, in den letzten Wochen.
Aber Atemnot oder Brust schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie früher auch noch etwas zu tun oder war das erst einmal?
Was habe ich noch nie gehabt, das ist neu.
Warst du im Nestes seit im Ausland?
Wie bitte?
Im Ausland?
Nein, ich bin nicht großvereist.
Ich war überhaupt nur in Deutschland, aber nicht im Ausland.
Ist Ihnen Herr Stolpern oder Herr Stolpern aufgefallen?
Was ist mir aufgefallen?
Herr Stolpern oder Herr Stolpern?
Herr Stolpern, nein.
Ich fühle mich in den letzten Wochen nicht mehr ganz so fit.
Ich bin nicht mehr ganz so meisternfähig.
Ich verstehe.
Ich fühle mich in den letzten Wochen nicht mehr ganz so fit.
Ich nehme etwas gegen hohe Blutdruck ein, ja?
Ja.
Ich glaube, seit ungefähr zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Ist dir Blutdruck gut eingeht, Herr Stolpern?
Ja, ich gehe nicht oft zur Kontrolle.
Aber mein Nachbar hat ein Blutdruckgerät, da mäß ich häufiger.
Und da ist er meistens immer gut.
Okay, sehr gut.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauenarztregelmäßig?
Und Frauenarzt alle zwei Jahre.
Okay, aber alles in Ordnung?
Bis jetzt war alles gut.
Wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Oh, das ist schon einige Jahre her.
Ich bin jetzt ja 64.
Ja, stimmt.
Das ist schon einige Jahre.
Kann ich mich gar nicht mehr genau erinnern.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben als chronischer Erkrankung nur Blutdruck.
Haben Sie andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, früher war mal das an der Schildrüse.
Da war eine kleine Unterfunktion.
Aber das hat sich dann wieder verbessert.
Ich verstehe, da habe ich nicht mehr.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert für Morgenszeit?
Ich wurde mal am Blindarm operiert als Kind.
Das ist aber auch so lange her.
Und da war alles in Ordnung.
Okay, alles gut.
Und nehmen Sie gegen Blutdruckmedikamente ein.
Wie heißt die Medikamente?
Ja, ich nehme ein Mittel ein.
Das Mittel heißt Kandisatan, 8 Milligramm.
Wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Morgens eine.
Noch etwas nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein.
Nein.
Ich habe auch eine Medikamente ein.
Ich habe noch ein Mittel, die ich nicht mehr habe.
Nein.
Okay, von morgen haben Sie allergien oder unverträglichen
Medikamente ein.
Manchmal denke ich im Frühjahr,
vielleicht etwas Blütenstaub, Blütenpollen.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Da brauche ich keine Medikamente.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie äußert sich die Polanalange?
Haben Sie Niesen?
Manchmal jucken die Augen etwas und ich Niese,
aber sonst nicht mehr.
Also ich brauche da glaube ich nichts einnehmen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Frau Morgenstein, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauke.
Seit wann und wie viele Zigaretten?
Ich brauche seit 40 Jahren.
Ich brauche so 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Okay, warst du ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, abends zum Abendbrot ein kleines Glas Wein.
Aber auch jeden Abend.
Ein kleines Glas, aber mehr nicht.
Ein Glas.
Sehr gut.
Frau Morgenstein, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist ganz Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und wie ist Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ab drei Kinder, die sind aber alle gesund.
Ja, sehr gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich war früher, war ich Busfahrerin.
Aber seit einem halben Jahr bin ich pensioniert.
Ah, okay.
Und leben Ihre Alten noch?
Nein, meine Mutter ist schon mit 60 Jahren verstorben.
Die hatte Darmkrebs.
Und mein Vater ist mit 78 Jahren verstorben.
Der ist an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, keine Schwester.
Keine Bruder.
Und die letzte Frage ist, sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Gegen Corona auch.
Ja, ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Und die anderen Impfungen, sagt mein Hausarzt,
sind ausreichend in Ordnung.
Okay, ja, sehr gut.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
So erst werde ich die körpärische Untersuchung,
dann werde ich Brut abnehmen.
Und ich mache Ultraschalt,
dann werde ich die Erkenntnisse wieder beschrieben.
Okay.
Okay, gut, danke schön.
Sagen wir in fünf Minuten.
Ja, okay, hat jemand Fragen?
Alle Fragen beantwortet.
Ja, stimmt.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit mehr nicht verändert?
Ja, ich habe fünf Kilo abgenommen.
Innerhalb von sechs Wochen.
Okay, das ist wichtig.
Ja, eine wichtige Frage.
Ja, ich habe vergessen, stimmt.
Okay, hat jemand Fragen?
Ja.
Ja, das wurde schon gefragt.
Ich habe gesagt, wenn ich die Knie etwas anziehe
und mich auf die Seite lege,
dann werden die Schmerzen etwas besser.
Aber nicht verbunden, ja?
Ich habe keinen Appetit.
Ich habe kaum etwas gegessen seit gestern.
Ich mag nicht essen.
Gut, machen wir.
Okay, bis gleich.
Ich bin bereit.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Mein Name ist Birgut.
Ich bin als Assistenzynthetik in der Notaufnahme.
Und ich würde gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen,
weil sie sagt, okay.
Frau Klardium Orgenstern ist 64 Jahre alt.
Und ein Meter, 66,
groß und 80 Kilogramm.
Frau Morgenstern,
ich tat es sich wegen,
seit gestern, 5 Jahren,
der Bau Schmerzen in der Mitte
auf der rechten Seite.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten
und immer stärkegeworden.
Und keine Auslöse
gab die Patientin an
für die Schmerzen.
Die Patientin beschert die Schmerzen
am Anfang als Stumm.
Dann werden sie aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Und ohne Auslöse.
Auf einmal schmerzen sie sich
für die Schmerzen.
Und die Schmerzen sind aufgetreten.
Und die Patientin hat keine Medikamente
eingehört.
Und die Körperhaltung mit angezogenen Beinen
liehnt der Schmerzen leicht.
Und außerdem klagt die Patientin über
Nausea in Appetence
und Fatigue
und Gewichtabnahme
von 5 Kilogramm
und 6 Wochen.
Und
Fragan, Fiba, MSS, Mixion und Defekation
störungen
und vorherigen Ennihenbecheverden
wurden ferneint.
Als vorher krankenden
die Patientin
die Leidung an Artiller-Hypertonöse
und eine Erleichterung
von 8 Kilogramm
von 8 Kilogramm.
Und als Kind
wurde appendectomy durchgeführt.
Die
Operation ist
Kommunikation-Social-Prozess.
Und zu ständen
hat die Patientin an Hypothyriose gelitten.
Und die Patientin hat Polinozis, die sich mit Yukreis und Niesen äußert.
Sie raut seit 40 Jahren, sen sigareteteklich, das entschüpft die 20-50 Jahre.
Sie trinkt, täglich, Angerblaswein, fragt nach Drogun, fragt nach Drogun,
wurde fernleinzt. Sie ist verheiratet, hat deralgesunde Kinder,
sie hat als Bulsfarerin gearbeitet, jetzt ist sie renntnerin.
Die Familie an Amnesi fand sich die Mutter mit sechs Jahren an Kolonkarstenum
verscht worden. Der Vater ist mit acht und sieb Jahren an
Myokart in der Verschtvorben. Und die Patientin ist verständlich geübt und sie ist in
der Meneposa. Danke, denken Sie dem, was ist Ihre Verdachtssiagnose, Frau Kollegin?
Als Anamnistischen Angabe durften auf am ersten Kolonkarstenum hin.
Warum? Die Patientin hat fünf Kilogramm abgenommen und Bauchschmerzen und die Patientin hat auch Familie veranlagelt.
Das sind gewichtige Faktoren. Man kann diese Verdachtssiagnose unterstützen.
Was kommt differentialdiagnostisch in Betracht?
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommt in akute Pancreatitis oder akute Colossistitis.
Oder eine entzündliche Damerkrankung?
Die Patientin hat keine Probleme beim Defekation, keine Durche, keine Obspasion.
Aber vielleicht das kann sein auch nicht.
Um meine Verdachtssiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich die Patientin körpärische untersuchen,
besonders Bauchabtastung und Abhören und Blutabnehmen, Instruktionsparameter,
Blutbild und Lebewerte und Amylaseolipolzen.
Können Sie mir noch sagen, wann der letzte Stuhl kam?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Doch, habe ich aber gesagt als Patient.
Vor zwei Tagen habe ich gesagt, weil letzte Stuhl war wichtig, auch noch bei der Untersuchung rektal untersuchen.
Also, ja stimmt.
Die am Pole Stöcke verlegt, das ist schon wichtig.
Ja, gut, bin ich mit einverstanden.
Haben Sie, denke ich, gut geschildert mit dem passenden und guten medizinischen Fachausdrücken?
War wichtig.
Bei der Anamnese kam die ganz entscheidende Frage, was hätten Sie denn für eine Diagnose gestellt, ohne die Gewichtsabnahme?
Ja, stimmt.
Aber die Kollegen haben diese Frage gestellt und ich habe die Leid.
Das wäre dann vielleicht etwas schwierig geworden.
Also immer daran denken.
Sie sagen ja, am Anfang immer, das machen Sie ja alle, dass Sie immer fragen,
wie alt, wie groß und wie schwer.
Und dann ist das Thema Gewicht oft erst mal fertig.
Aber die Frage nach den Gewichtsverhalten, denke ich, ist auch in diesem Zusammenhang natürlich sehr wichtig.
Ich habe noch als Patientin gesagt, zwischendurch in den letzten Wochen habe ich mich müde gefühlt und nicht so leistungsfähig.
Auch da vielleicht dran denken, oh, oh, was kann dahinterstecken?
Ein konsumierender Prozess, ein Krebsgälden oder so.
Also da immer ein bisschen darauf achten, aber die Frage nach dem Gewicht und Gewichtsverhalten,
das ist, glaube ich, eine sehr wichtige Frage, in diesem Fall besonders, für eine diagnostische Einordnung.
Ja, stimmt.
Ja gut. Aber so, sonst, finde ich, haben Sie das sehr gut gemacht.
Dankeschön.
Sie können sich gut prüfen lassen.
Ja, danke. Ich hoffe auch.
Wann ist die Prüfung?
19. Mai.
19. Mai, der prima.
Ja.
So, da meldet sich auch schon der Moderator, sehe ich, im Bild.
Das ist sehr gut.
Okay, also nächste Woche kann ich nicht, da bin ich nicht da.
Aber nächste Woche können wir gleich einen Termin machen.
Okay.
Ja, vielleicht wieder am Dienstag.
Um 18 Uhr.
Okay.
Ja?
Ja.